I
you
check one two check one two one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
check one two one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
check one two one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
check one two one two audio good all
right good
[Music]
you
success rate at getting people who are
positive to be undetectable by being
compliant with their drugs and then if
you're negative but you have behaviors
that put you at risk for getting HIV you
can take prep you can take the product
that with compliance it keeps you 97%
chance that you won't get the HIV
disease also and so the tools are there
it's about execution and blocking and
tackling and that's what the president's
leading and we've gotten the funding
from Congress for this so we really have
this in our grasp but the tools were
there but it took president Trump's call
to action to make this a reality I was
being briefed and they told me that this
is a possibility if we wanted to do it I
said who wouldn't want to do this and
everything is a lot of money but this is
small money compared to what we're
talking about and I'm somebody from New
York who lost a lot of friends to AIDS a
tremendous number of friends some of the
most talented people that I knew I lost
to AIDS and it's incredible do you have
anything to add to what because you are
I mean you're the real expert on AIDS
and the eradication anything to add
about eradication in our country we just
appreciate the government's support on
doing both domestic work and global work
on HIV AIDS because obviously you also
are invest in than the PEPFAR program to
really bring the same level of
compassion and treatment to people
around the globe to really control the
epidemic around the globe and this is a
big step forward for all of us what do
you think of the timing is am i right
when I say about eight years well we are
always to actually control the pandemic
to make it controllable and smaller
that's absolutely possible to eradicate
it obviously we need a vaccine or a cure
there are groups working on that under
your direction to really ensure the kind
we make forward progress in vaccines and
then a little step backwards and then
forward progress it's tough work and the
cure is tough work but your scientists
are working on it around the clock and
around the world good that'll be true
please well thanking this president I
just appreciate the opportunity to
express the gratitude that we all feel
dan to you and the incredible team that
Gillian I mean to think of the progress
that you've made in such an
extraordinary period of time when the
president brought the pharmaceutical
companies here to the White House you
were among them
he said we wanted you to move out
quickly on developing vaccine but he
said develop the therapeutics as quickly
as you can we were told that it was
possible that by the spring we would
have therapeutics and standing here on
May the first the very first therapeutic
with the emergency use authorization a
good work of FDA is now available and
but donating 1.5 million doses our task
force will be working very closely with
Gilead to make sure that those medicines
starting on Monday are distributed to
hospitals where patients are struggling
in serious conditions with the
coronavirus today and so i dan I just I
hope you will carry back our gratitude
but I know the gratitude of the American
people when they see the incredible
ingenuity and generosity of the team at
Gilead god bless you thank you very much
mr. president appreciate it and Adam
maybe you could say a few words you were
very instrumental in getting us to be
the kings and queens of
starting with almost none from the past
what do you have to say I think
pneumatically it shows the strength of
the public-private partnerships that
you've led that you the vice-president
that all of us have been working on you
talked about ventilators
I know mr. vice president you just
visited the GM plan you were looking you
saw GE baking ventilators how quickly we
moved there right this is just another
example where you have a company one of
our best that came up with the first
therapeutic that shows the strength of
our private business the other thing I
know that you guys did dan and I really
appreciate is you didn't wait to start
production and that means we're gonna
get doses next week because they ramped
up production and didn't wait because
they wanted to help Americans so I think
it shows the strength of our private
business and I'm very proud to be in
America you were so confident in what
you were doing early on that you were
able to really weren't but we but we saw
the incredible human need and we said
any event that this is successful we
have to plan for success and that's just
the way that we operate I'm proud to
work for a company that type of decision
and how many doses are we getting from
the standpoint of the country and the
contribution so we I mean we're
particularly with the news around the
fact that some patients as dr. Hahn
mentioned can benefit from only five
days of treatment which i think is a
real benefit by the way for patients to
get five days of IV e and if they're
improving to get out of the hospital
great for them to get back to the loved
ones great for reducing the burden on
the healthcare system and then that 1.5
million doses goes longer right so we're
talking you know about hundreds more
than a hundred thousand treatment
courses which again we need more and
we're still ramping up and we're going
to have more in the second half of the
year at least but at least it's a start
and the most severe the most serious
patients I think we're the ones that
we'll work with with the vice president
on his team on to make sure that we get
it to the most serious patients first
that's a great start thank you very much
thank gilja very much that's fantastic
we'll be seeing you all in a little
while thank you very much thank you